en un vídeo anterior dimos un vistazo al
mercado de trabajo y lo analizamos en el
contexto del mercado completo y cómo
puede impactar a una empresa digamos que
de pronto cambia la política de
inmigración del país y ahora se permite
la entrada a más personas que tienen las
habilidades para participar en el
mercado de trabajo que estamos
analizando cuando se abre la inmigración
y comienzan a llegar más personas al
país qué va a ocurrir en este mercado de
trabajo pausa en el vídeo y piensan en
cuál será la nueva cantidad de
equilibrio el nuevo salario de
equilibrio y cómo afectará esto a esta
empresa vamos a resolverlo juntos si de
pronto hay mucha inmigración de personas
que pueden participar en este mercado va
a aumentar la oferta en cualquier
salario dado si esta es la curva de
oferta del mercado de trabajo que
llamaremos sub 1 se va a desplazar a la
derecha y para cualquier salario habrá
más trabajadores
esta es la curva de oferta del mercado
de trabajo sub 2 cómo afecta esto a la
cantidad y el salario de equilibrio el
nuevo salario de equilibrio va a ser
menor que ya
w 2 con un asterisco y tenemos una
cantidad de equilibrio más grande q sub
2 asterisco que le pasa a esta empresa
pues ha disminuido el salario de
equilibrio y como suponemos que esta
empresa está en un mercado de
competencia perfecta esta empresa va a
pagar lo que indique el salario del
mercado así que el costo marginal del
factor cmg efe de la empresa se ha
desplazado abajo este era el costo
marginal del factor 1 y ahora tenemos el
costo marginal del factor 2 por lo que
ahora es racional para la empresa
contratar a más personas
esta es curso 1 y esta nueva excusa 2
que otras cosas pueden causar que se
desplace a la derecha la curva de oferta
del mercado de trabajo acabamos de
mencionar la inmigración al país también
podemos imaginar que más personas que ya
se encuentran en el país tienen la
posibilidad de participar en este
mercado de trabajo por ejemplo en la
segunda mitad del siglo 20 se volvió
aceptable el que las mujeres
participaran en la fuerza laboral donde
de pronto tenemos a todas
mujeres dispuestas a entrar al mercado
de trabajo para cierta industria también
puede desplazar esta curva a la derecha
ahora pensemos en lo contrario
imaginemos que hay migración neta que
sale del país que le pasará a la curva
de oferta del mercado de trabajo en este
caso se desplazará a la izquierda más o
menos así para cierto salario habrá
menos personas dispuestas a trabajar
esta es la curva de oferta del mercado
de trabajo sub 3 hay otras cosas que
pueden ocasionar esto quizá cambien las
preferencias de las personas y es
posible que en este mercado en
particular las personas ya no estén
dispuestas a trabajar en él quizá
cambiaron las normas sociales y ya no se
ve bien trabajar en ese mercado de
trabajo o quizá hay otro mercado de
trabajo en otra industria que de pronto
comienza a pagar mejor en esta situación
habrá menos personas que quieran
trabajar en este mercado cuando la curva
se desplaza a la izquierda el salario
del mercado va a aumentar
wv sub 3 y la cantidad de trabajo va a
disminuir q sub 3 asterisco
y vemos un impacto en una empresa
particular en un mercado de trabajo en
competencia perfecta este será el costo
marginal del factor para una empresa que
participe en este mercado y ahora la
cantidad de trabajo que contratar a esta
empresa va a disminuir q sub 3 a este
disco esto que acabamos de ver quizá no
les sorprenda mucho ya que los mercados
de trabajo se comportan de forma muy
similar a los mercados de otras cosas si
muchos trabajadores entran al mercado de
trabajo la curva de oferta de trabajo se
desplazará a la derecha y si muchos
trabajadores salen del mercado de
trabajo o ya no quieren estar en él se
desplazará a la izquierda la curva de
oferta de trabajo